you'd be surprised how many people were
on the top one day and are no longer in
the industry anymore because they were
focused on being a youtuber but when
you're focused on being a youtube
preneur you're building entirely
different
welcome to the think media podcast my
name is heather torres your host of this
podcast and we're here to help you grow
your influence on youtube and then turn
that influence into a high impact and a
high profit online business and if
you're new to the podcast i want to
welcome you thank you so much for
joining us here i hope a friend referred
you or maybe you were just interested in
figuring out how to do this youtube
thing and i want to welcome you we
release a brand new podcast every single
tuesday and then we have bonus content
over on our youtube channel we have a
podcast youtube channel called the think
media podcast and wow guys we just made
it over 50 000 subscribers over on that
channel and i'm so excited because you
made that possible and it's been
incredible to read your comments and
hear all about how the podcast is
helping you grow your influence online
and then turn that influence into the
high impact and high profit youtube
channel we have a lot happening at think
media for you and i want to let you know
about our upcoming five day free youtube
challenge if you've been ready to start
your youtube channel or you want to
figure out how to grow your youtube
channel this is the five day free
challenge for you we just did this
challenge earlier this year and saw
massive results from people inside of
our community and so we decided to offer
it again for the spring so if you've not
been a part of one of our free five day
youtube challenges you want to go to
tube1kchallenge.com to get registered
for that event now this is going to be
five days of free training that we
normally give inside of our academy
you're gonna get access to that for free
we have some different options for you
when you go there so make sure you
register today to claim your spot for
our free five day challenge well today's
episode is going to come from one of our
grow with video live sessions that we
had last year growth video live is the
annual conference that we do here at
think media it's happening again live
this year in person in may i'll tell you
more about that later on in the episode
but this session is all about how are
you going to succeed on youtube and
create consistent success how do you
create consistent success sean's going
to be breaking down the youtube
domination framework and we're going to
share with you how you can avoid some of
the pitfalls that can lead to burnout
and how to be sustainable on youtube as
you're growing your business i can't
wait for you to dive into today's
episode get your pens ready to take some
notes and let's head into the featured
content
[Music]
the youtube domination framework how do
we create consistent success
on
youtube um and i want to start with just
a quick story you know i met my wife
sonia in 2004
we got married in 2005 and then we
bought our first house in 2006.
if you do the math and you've been
around long enough
then you know that that was that was a
horrible time to buy a house uh we
experienced that
a few years later obviously the big
short happened and so uh but we bought
our first house uh in in in 2006 now
this house was built
in
1969 and what i learned about
uh houses is that especially if they're
really old like that and maybe there's
there's of course even older houses the
1969 is pretty old and uh that you need
to budget a lot of money for repairs
like i don't know if you follow personal
finance people like dave ramsey they're
like if you're gonna buy an older house
you need to budget money for repairs and
so we kind of learned this lesson that
if you're ever gonna build something you
need to start with the end in mind you
need to kind of think about the
complexities and things that will be
coming up and things like that
well we didn't do that so we bought this
house we barely got into it right on a
80 20 arm that's a horrible loan never
do one of those and we it was baseboard
heating there was like no insulation in
the wall so it's super expensive to do
that electric heating
and we uh
so we get to this house and we had
roommates to even be able to afford the
mortgage
and the balloon payment that would come
up and and uh we were living in
washington which is freezing during the
winter but here was our our standard for
the house the standard was you're
actually not allowed you can only heat
your room we had michael carey jessie
tillman living in rooms and then my wife
and i as a new married couple with the
thinnest paper walls you could ever
imagine with three bedrooms clustered
together closer than you could ever
imagine you want to talk about awkward
when it's netflix and chill time netflix
didn't even exist yet listen and so we
here was the rule because we were so
penny pinching
that that there was a wood fireplace and
we said listen
you can't use the baseboard heaters in
the house
if you want the house to be warm michael
jesse you have to build a fire now you
can heat your room because it's just
like a small like 500 square foot room
or 400 or something but but you can't
heat the house that's how tight we were
with finances well here's the problem
when you're barely getting into
a house and you can't even turn on the
baseboard heaters because that'll cause
your electric bill to go too high
and you need roommates to barely afford
the payment
you clearly did not budget enough money
for the challenges that may come with an
older house
and boy we learned that the hard way let
me just tell you and so this old house
we get into it and not a month after we
start looking in the bathrooms and we go
wait a minute is that black mold coming
through the walls like is that black
mole next thing you know we are demoing
an entire bathroom
we're just we're tearing up we're and
we're trying to do the work ourselves
like we're we're hiring some contractors
but i'm like breaking up tile that's
from 1969 black mold we're discovering
things what is rotting that was bathroom
number one
god is my witness two months later
bathroom number two same issue black
mold which is like deadly
right as if that was the worst challenge
uh
we we discovered that uh that the roof
was leaking like crazy and sagging
because they had put three roofs of
shingles which is the amount of roofs
you can put
shingles you can put before having to
totally tear the roof off
in addition to that the drain field
failed okay
and that's the end of the conference
like just the level of depression i'm
going into remembering now see when
you're on a septic tank if your drain
field fails that's a seven to eight
thousand dollar repair uh and and uh and
so
here's the thing there's a couple
lessons that i learned um about this a
lot of lessons number one
you got to start with the end in mind
and whenever you're getting into a
situation you got to ask yourself have i
budgeted
enough money have i budgeted enough time
have i budgeted enough resource
for what may come up on the journey the
truth is had i got wisdom i wouldn't
actually have been that surprised by
those things like older house like you
you should be ready for it you shouldn't
get in over your head you should count
the cost of buying an older house
yes furthermore you want to make sure
you work with the right people like if i
could go back and talk to the inspector
and if we could have an exchange like
i'm a man of peace typically
but when i talk about it would it be
punch fear in the face it would be punch
the inside i'm just kidding maybe the
inspector in the face because it was
funny we were just trying to get the
house the agent was like let's just get
the thing pushed through so he approved
the leaky roof he didn't really go into
detail in terms of mold tests or any
things like that i i wish i would have
had listen a coach that really cares
a a mentor that could really help me
avoid the pitfalls you know a guide that
could really tell me the real truth and
that could really get my wife and i
prepared for what we were going to get
into you know this reminds me
of a story that's actually in the bible
and and jesus once said listen if you
want to build a tower like suppose
somebody wants to build a tower wouldn't
you first sit down and estimate the cost
to complete it
and then he's saying so that way you
wouldn't get halfway into building and
then get ridiculed because you're like
oh shoot i mean the tower was going to
be a hundred grand but i only had 50.
like it's just that's some biblical
wisdom like count the cost
before building
you know i share this story because at
the foundation our goal is to start with
the end
in mind is to reverse engineer and is to
really lay a foundation and count the
cost
before building you know today uh my
wife and i now have been married
um coming up on 16 years our anniversary
september 9th now we have a son sean
bradley can't look at him there he's a
little chaos candidate just a total
tyrant like he is and and he's not even
fully walking right now he's climbing on
things it's total destruction i mean i
live in just mayhem in my life right now
but but now that i've been through the
years of
total financial devastation from houses
and business failures and things like
that i've seen i'm a little bit older
now i'm coming up on 38 years old you
get wisdom over the years and the power
of being here is to shorten your
learning curve and listen friend avoid
potentially months even years of
heartache and pain in building a youtube
career because you're learning from
those that have already made the
mistakes
but now that i'm in kind of this season
of looking back and a lot of reflection
i've been asking myself some questions
write these down some business questions
like what am i building
write that down like what is it i'm even
building
what do i want to build
yes youtube but even bigger than youtube
what is my
long-term strategy
what's my what's my long-term
strategy with this
how about some life or or some health
questions
is this
sustainable
now we can go through sacrifice seasons
but i want you to pick a youtube niche
a youtube channel a youtube strategy a
youtube schedule
that is
sustainable because the problem with an
unsustainable pace
is that it's unsustainable
right
so
our intentionality to make decisions
before we build the tower before we buy
the 1969 house is to say okay
do we have the budget for this the time
for this how can we
what are the details to start with the
end of end in mind
what about some legacy questions
what kind of example this is what i've
been asking what kind of example am i
setting for my son and what am i doing
for the next generation
now i get it you might be like sean what
the heck are we can we get into some
youtube strategy we're going in there
we're going quick it'll be zero to 100
real quick but this is so important and
i feel compelled and convicted to start
here
because if you don't start with the end
in mind
you might end up
at the wrong destination
if you don't know where you're going
how will you know when you get there
fair there's seven r's in our youtube
success framework our youtube success
formula and the first one is reverse
engineer this is where we start with the
end in mind now write this down when
you're reverse engineering here's what
you're doing
a lot of times you're asking first and
foremost what is the purpose of my
youtube channel
how is my youtube channel going to make
money
what is the business model around my
youtube channel
who is the bigger audience my youtube
channel is targeting all those types of
things
we don't just reverse engineer our
channel though we also reverse engineer
each video so you can re-go through the
7r framework and at the beginning you go
okay i'm going to record a video this
week
who is this video for
how is this video going to make money
why would people want to click on this
video what is the title of this video i
know i'm firing these questions at you
fast and so uh but we're gonna keep
going deeper and this is the purpose of
reverse engineer which brings us
to what we call the youtube domination
framework the youtube domination
framework so i want you to write this in
your notes
and you could draw out this um
x y axis uh you know
plane here and write a 0 at the bottom
and write a 10 at the top of each one
and and this right here is a framework
that will help us
reverse engineer where it is we want to
go with our youtube channel okay and so
draw that out and here's what the
accesses stand for the first one is
views at the bottom is views if you're
going to succeed on youtube you're going
to need to get views how many you get
will determine potentially the level of
success right and so if you have no
views it doesn't matter anything else
that's happening in your business
literally nobody is seeing your content
and obviously especially when you've
built other
details and opportunities more views
just means more
traffic coming into your business now if
you're new to kind of online marketing
terms the word traffic can kind of be
interchanged for views so we say like
how much traffic is your youtube channel
or your website getting how many views
is your channel getting now on the other
access it's money
it's money you need money for the
mission
entrepreneurs solve problems for a
profit
and so on the bottom access you have how
many views is my channel getting and
then on the other side you have how much
money is my channel earning and there's
really four categories we can fall into
when it comes to the youtube domination
framework and uh let's dive into those
right now and i want to know which one
can you relate with the most the first
one is the dabbler the dabbler okay the
dabbler is out of season and at a stage
where views and money are both pretty
low or maybe non-existent so far now
here's some ways that you would know
you're a dabbler first of all you're
just not taking youtube serious yet
that's fine but chances are you just by
joining this conference is showing
you're like okay i want to shift from
dabbling and start moving into some
discipline of taking youtube serious
because you might be a dabbler though
if you consume more videos than you
create
how much are you consuming how much are
you watching and maybe it's not even
consume more youtube videos how many
seasons of the flash did you just binge
you know how many seasons of arrow or
the bachelor you know what are we
talking about like are you consuming
more content than you're creating if we
are youtube content creators and youtube
entrepreneurs we need to create more
than we consume but we're probably
dabbling and kind of just talking
if we're actually not taking action and
creating you're you might be a dabbler
if you are dreaming more than you do
dream more than you do
i i hope you brought steel-toed shoes
today because i'm going to be stepping
on your toes but listen
you might be getting a you might be a
dabbler if you're getting distracted by
shiny objects okay i'm going to build on
youtube but someone just told me tiktok
is the coolest thing okay now i'm trying
to do tick-tock but someone just told me
that you know facebook is experiencing a
revival now i'm going back on facebook
but someone just told me there's this
cool conference and this cool webinar i
should watch cool but someone just told
me i should get this new software and
you're just going in a million different
directions can you relate to that how do
you start and grow a youtube channel
that makes you money and also makes a
major impact in the lives of people it's
safe to say that youtube is the most
popular video platform in the world it's
the second largest search engine and the
second most popular social media
platform and now it has over 2.3 billion
monthly active users that's a lot but
how do you stand out in the rising
competition what are the newest features
and the best strategies working right
now to get views what are the most
proven ways to build your personal brand
you'll learn all of that at the number
one youtube marketing conference for
entrepreneurs and business-minded
content creators grow with video live
secure your ticket today at
growethvideolive.com or you can click
the link in this post to secure your
limited time discounted ticket you might
be
thinking here's the problem you maybe
you're right now thinking let me know
are you thinking about starting two
channels is there two channels you want
to start maybe three or four youtube
channels do you already have a youtube
channel
but you're like there's actually another
youtube channel i want to start but the
views and the money haven't even kicked
in yet
and you're already thinking about
starting another channel that is a
dabbler
attribute
because it's you haven't got focused yet
you haven't got disciplined yet it's
okay if that's where you are but again
we're reverse engineering
if we want to determine where we want to
go in the future
we also need to define where we are
right now so we can chart a path to that
destination
and so that's the dabbler now everybody
starts at zero everybody starts at zero
so being a dabbler is uh you might have
a genuine desire to you know succeed on
youtube but at this stage you're
uncommitted so your action here is to
stop dabbling and to start dominating
now the second one if you graduate if
you graduate from being the dabbler next
you move into being the influencer being
the influencer and congratulations
because it takes a lot of work and it
takes some success and even some luck to
get to
the influencer stage
like you might at this point you have
some videos with a lot of views you
might even say like sean it's crazy like
you go to my channel i got this one
video it's got like 186 000 views
and you're like that's amazing like
think about that like i'm a small town
kid college dropout if a video has 5 000
views that's insane if a video has 25
000 views that's bigger than the town i
grew up in however then you go okay well
is money coming in no i mean
not really i don't really know how to
monetize like i got the attention i mean
i get like
seven dollars from adsense a month it's
incredible right i'm doing youtube
shorts you know and i just made six
cents it's a it's incredible but again
you maybe have some videos with a lot of
use maybe you even have a lot of
subscribers
and you might be posting a lot of
content so you're on this like content
treadmill i'm posting posting a lot of
content kind of exhausted though man on
that influencer path are you an
influencer yeah you enjoy your life
yeah i do
i'm about to have a breakdown like you
know because you're just hustling trying
to get the views trying to get the
subscribers trying to keep up with the
demands
of being an influencer
and the weakness of being an influencer
is i've met influencers
that are actually living paycheck to
paycheck
over the last couple years successful
influencers that are living paycheck to
paycheck over the last couple years i've
been to i can't even count how many
events when i think about the lanyards
youtube conferences social media
conferences online marketing conferences
i've got like a hundred of the lanyards
uh i used to collect them and then i
realized you know it's like my wife's
like do you really need these i'm like
yes they're mementos are you a hoarder
i'm a hoarder
admittedly i am a hoarder like this is a
separate marriage counseling
conversation um but but i've been in so
many conferences and you would not
believe how many people i've talked to
and how many people i've connected with
that are like bro i mean like the
numbers like i'm killing it um
subscribers are growing but like we're
kind of struggling like we're trying to
keep up with everything so they have a
lot of influence but they haven't really
figured out the business side
of
youtube and
you might have listen the metrics you
measure
um if it's your subscriber count you're
you know you're an influencer if what
you're measuring is your subscriber
account
but not your bank account
and i've never been able to go to bank
of america and be like hey check out
here's my silver play button can i
deposit that can you turn this into cash
for me now silver play buttons are cool
but they're actually not really worth
any money like it's not real silver
that's one thing you learn i have a gold
play button it's not real gold and so
like i thought you actually got it cool
melt it down you're like this is worth
so to a point i get it influence is
powerful and congratulations if you
build influence
but ultimately you can find yourself
sort of stuck
and
your other worry
is what happens if this 15 minutes of
fame ends
because the problem with being an
influencer is you're hot today but
you're maybe not hot tomorrow if you're
not built upon something bigger than you
just kind of being
trendy or cool or entertaining or
building around a fad or building around
a trend
then more power to you but the 15
minutes of fame
may end and then you're back to where
you started
so then it brings us to the next
category and let me know which one you
can relate to the most
is the pusher
see the the the dabbler is kind of just
getting started and hasn't gotten
serious yet the influencer has really
figured out how to get views but maybe
hasn't figured out the business side now
the pusher
has figured out the business side
has figured out a business model has
something to sell
and is good at making money
now you you maybe come into youtube and
you are in network marketing or you
already have a product or a service and
i know the the pusher term i don't mean
it to sound too pushy but the reason
it's called pusher
is because your views are so low you're
desperate
to make sales
you don't have enough traffic and
awareness and attraction marketing
happening that people are coming to you
because of the views scale
you are just trying to you know send out
another email drop another video try to
get somebody else into your program or
into your consulting or into whatever it
is so in this stage you just feel like
you gotta push and push and push
and push
no matter how hard you push you do get
it done but it feels like a grind
to keep generating the money so it's
like the opposite side that the
influence the influencer is trying to
figure out how to have some kind of a
business model the pusher is trying to
figure out how to get enough awareness
enough leads get in front of enough
potential customers to actually have a
legitimate business and a legitimate
impact and the problem is nobody likes a
pushy salesman right
like the best way to market is to sell
or to market pressure free
like i hope that's the way you feel
about think media and of course not
everybody feels that way but if you
realize that like we are always like hey
you know if if you want a ticket to this
thing get it if not then don't
like if you want to join video rake
academy it's the greatest program on the
planet like you should but like if you
don't want to you don't have to like you
want to watch
and that's where you want to be because
you want to have just enough people so
you don't ever feel this is huge
that like you have to get the car
off the car a lot like the car salesman
because you have to hit a quota like
you're just desperate to get enough to
survive
so obviously then the dream becomes if
we look at our diagram here
that i want you to even consider where
are you at are you maybe a three on
views
and maybe a 10 on making money in that
case you'd be doing pretty good because
you have a business model you just get a
little bit of traffic this is why i
think about carrie who has 5 000
subscribers and is doing over i believe
10k a month it's because and he helps
people create print-on-demand shops he's
doing merch stuff he's doing online
courses he's got coach he's got
affiliate marketing he's got all these
different income streams built so i
would say he's like a 10 on the money
he's not even having he's not even
really a pusher because even on views is
probably three or a two but because he's
a 10 here he's actually really making a
huge impact you know and even maybe
you're really kind of more of an
entertainer you have a bigger wider
niche you could be like an eight on
views and a three on money and you're
still probably making a big impact
because you're growing both sides of it
the question is man what's the business
side what's the money side what is the
view side and how can i increase both
that's what we're committed to here is
helping you say
man how do i get more views but how do i
also build a sustainable business around
my youtube channel this is so powerful
and i want to commend you
for
the courage to identify where you are
because again once we know where we are
now we can chart a path
to where we want to go
and where is it that we want to go
well there's a fourth area
the fourth area and that
is what we call the youtubepreneur we've
defined a term here and and coined this
term here at think media called
youtubepreneurs so what's a
youtubepreneur let's look at our
definition
a youtubepreneur is an individual who
has built a sustainable
keyword sustainable is this sustainable
profitable
and scalable business keyword
on youtube
that generates consistent views and
revenue and is not dependent
on one income source
i really want you to absorb this you
could screenshot it you could share it
you know screen take a picture use the
hashtag grow with video because our goal
is to help you become
a youtube preneur i'm not suggesting
that it's easy but i am suggesting that
it is simple because if you're
intentional then you are approaching
this different than most
a lot of people it's crazy like that we
think i want to be a youtuber like we
talked about in that bonus session i
just want to be a youtuber how are you
going to make money i don't know i just
figure if i get a million views then i
can pay my bills
that is
because we've heard of unicorns that
achieved that the problem is even if
somebody achieves that once though where
are they eight months later or 16 months
later
can it you'd be surprised how many
people have been at vidcon for like the
last seven years you'd be surprised how
many people were on the top one day and
are no longer in the industry anymore
because they were focused on being a
youtuber
but when you're focused on being a
youtube preneur you're building entirely
different
your strategy is entirely different your
thinking is entirely different and what
you do today is going to determine where
you end up tomorrow so it's really
important that we build well it's really
important that going into this like my
wife and i buying a 1969 year old house
maybe budgeted some money and determined
if we even had the resources and the
funds and the strategy and the
positioning
to to not get into a ton of trouble with
that house and ultimately end up losing
it right a youtube preneur and so let's
define what a youtube preneur is right
we could be at the dabbler phase the
influencer phase the pusher face i would
say that
if you could get to a 10 10 level right
10 10 living like if you literally go
okay we know how to consistently create
views and we know how to consistently
create money and of course hear me this
is this means you're also consistently
adding value you're consistently
building relationships like you it's
it's that mastery level it's that
mastery target level
the 1010 level might take 10 years
you hang out with think media it might
take five but this is not overnight like
this is going to take some investment so
here's what a youtube
preneur has done
write this down you've created
and defined a clear vision
of the people you help
and the problem you solve
youtubers have created
and they have defined a clear vision
of who it is they help and the problem
they solve
what's think media is well think media
we are heavily on youtube
but if you think deeply about that you
might say well what if youtube is not
around forever it's a reasonable
question
and all the data and everything is
pointing to youtube in terms of this
next decade is going to be the best
decade on youtube it's an absolute
juggernaut we are unafraid to make the
bet we're making on youtube but our
business
is actually online video because i'll
tell you this online video is not going
anywhere
and um and not only that online
marketing and the skill sets we're
developing
no matter what we're going to be live
streaming no matter what we're going to
be creating content no matter what we're
going to be creating videos and so even
though you may plant your flag today
what's the bigger vision
right that you're building towards
so you've created and defined a clear
vision of the people you help in the
problem you solved you've mastered
getting consistent and predictable
traffic and views from youtube you've
mastered generating consistent and
predictable revenue
from youtube
but also from multiple channels
like right now think media has over 21
income streams
and many of them they're not all based
on youtube
and many of them come in without any
continual effort from our part a little
bit of management
so you've you've set what you've you
have automation working for you it's a
big word you want automation in your
business don't you i want autopilot in
my tesla
rather than so i it can drive for me so
that i could do other things probably
not good someone's just like reading a
book i know you have to okay uh
automation automation
listen write this down you've mastered
modern marketing in online business
you've mastered
modern marketing and online business and
here's a big one
you don't feel like you're on a
treadmill headed for burnout
now hear me we're casting vision because
i think it's so important that we define
what a 10 10 future looks like
it's so important that we clarify where
we want to go there's a lot of pain and
struggle and wandering on the journey
like i can tell you there's been some
seasons many where i have felt like i've
been on the verge of burnout but the key
thing to do was was to steer away from
that season and to make chess moves and
to make decisions and to position things
and to look down the road a little bit a
lot of times we just don't ask the
question of where is this going is this
sustainable what do i need to do today
to position myself for where i want to
be tomorrow
and so which one can you relate to and
if you're ready say i'm ready to become
a youtube entrepreneur
well i hope that content sparked some
interest for you of figuring out where
are you inside of the youtube domination
framework how are you going to create
sustainable success and what actions do
you need to put in place in order to be
successful on youtube like i said at the
beginning that episode actually is from
our session at groweth video live and
this year's growth video live is going
to be like none other we are back in
person here in las vegas uh in may of
2022. you can get your tickets at
growethvideolive.com
but i am so excited to see all of the
think media community there in person um
thank you for those who have already
gotten your tickets because tickets are
going so fast for this event it's
amazing to see uh the video ranking
academy community the inner circle
community and our think media community
at large
showing up for this event so uh i want
to let you know that um you can get
access to that uh with sessions like
this if you want to at
growwithvideolive.com but every single
episode i love to shout out someone from
our think media community it's so fun to
see all of the reviews that are coming
in um and those that are rating and
reviewing the podcast over on apple
podcast this helps us so much to be able
to show other people what they can
expect from the podcast you know when
you when you go and you're trying to
look for new content it's really great
to be able to read reviews about exactly
what you're going to learn i have been
on so many podcasts before where i'm
like i wish people would just say in the
comments what they love about this and
what i can get if i spend my time with
these people and so thank you so much
think community for showing up so well
inside of the rating and reviewing over
on
apple because that's helping us get in
front of more and more people
today's review comes from andrew and
andrew says inspiring and helpful five
stars incredible podcast that has
motivated me to start my own youtube
channel and podcasts sean is amazing 10
10 such a great listen oh my goodness
andrew congratulations on starting your
own youtube channel you don't need
permission from anyone to get started
but the fact that you decided that this
was the thing that had that was the
catalyst into you getting started oh
makes my heart so happy so thank you for
being a part of our community thank you
for
sharing that with other people and if
you've not already shared this with a
friend
you could have a friend like andrew in
your life who needs to hear what is
happening over here on the think media
podcast i want to thank you again for
being a part of our community thank you
for staying with us through this journey
and we have so much amazing content
planned for you in the future as we get
closer into grow with video live you're
going to be hearing from some of our
main speakers who are going to be there
and then we are going to have some in
in-depth conversations more about the
mindset and the things that creators are
struggling with we have so much planned
for you coming up in the spring and
summer
stay locked in here if you're watching
on youtube you can like and subscribe if
you're listening to this in the car
walking the dog out on the boat wherever
you are right now i want to say thank
you for being a part of this amazing
community i'm so encouraged every time i
get to read your comments on youtube and
see what you are doing because of the
power of this community so thank you so
much for being with us and we'll catch
you in the next episode do you want to
learn how to get to your first 1000
subscribers and beyond join us for our
free five day youtube challenge where
you're going to learn exactly what's
working on youtube right now and the
latest strategies to help you grow save
your spot at tube1kchallenge.com
you